BIG TECH WON:
For decades, the goal of big tech has
been clear and absolute: growth over everything
else. Regardless of what obstacle came up, they
were willing to push through no matter the cost.
Whether it was concerns regarding privacy or data
collection or predatory pricing or monopolistic
practices or anti trust lawsuits or whatever,
big tech kept charging forward hoping to maximize
their user count. And for the longest time,
this strategy worked. The more they pushed, the
further they were able to reach. They were able to
convince whole new demographics and even countries
to adopt their technology. And over time, all of
this growth has allowed big tech to be some of the
most powerful, influential, and wealthy companies
in the entire world, but it seems that big tech
is finally facing a challenge that they can’t just
brute force their way through: market saturation.
This was historically something that most tech
companies did not even consider simply because
their target market was virtually everyone with
an internet connection. But, guess what? Everyone
with an internet connection now already uses most
of the popular services offered by big tech. Take
WhatsApp for example. In Brazil, they control
98.9% of the market. In Indian, they control
97.9%. In Italy, they control 97%. In Argentina,
they control 96% and so on and so forth. And
it’s not like they can grow in the countries
where they don’t control nearly a 100% either
because the rest of the market in these countries
aren’t exactly open. They’re just controlled by
another big tech offering whether that be iMessage
or Android Messaging and this is the case with
basically every major industry. Chrome has 3.2
billion users, Android has 3.3 billion users,
YouTube has 2.7 billion users, Facebook has 2.9
billion users, Instagram has 2.3 billion users,
and on and on ad on. And when you combine all
of these market shares, you’ll see that big tech
already controls virtually the entire internet.
In fact, just Google, Netflix, Facebook, Apple,
Amazon, and Microsoft control 57% of all global
internet traffic. So, safe to say that big
tech has officially won the game, so what now?
STAGNATION IS A KILLER:
Big tech reaching market saturation
may not seem like a big deal. After all, how hard
could it be to just be the king of the hill and
make billions every week right? Well, that would
be true if making billions every week was truly
the end goal for these companies. For most of
these companies, there is no concrete end goal.
Their goal was to just grow infinitely. And given
that tech is able to reach a larger demographic
than any previous industry, this strategy was
viable for decades. But, now that they’ve reached
market saturation, the goal becomes a lot harder.
Now, you’re probably wondering, why does that even
matter? Couldn’t these companies just hang up
their hats and call it day and enjoy market
saturation? Well, they could definitely hang up
their hats but they wouldn’t really be able enjoy
it because many of these companies would end up
losing hundreds of billions of dollars because the
only thing holding up their massive valuations is
infinite growth. Take Apple for example. They’re
currently worth just under $3 trillion but on an
annual basis, they only make a little over a $100
billion. Now, that’s obviously an insane amount of
money but what we’re really concerned about is the
ratio between their valuation and their annual
earnings or their PE ratio which is currently
about 30. In other words, if you were to buy the
entirety of Apple right now and they stop growing,
it would take you 30 years to make all your
money back. And even then, on your $3 trillion
investment, you’d only be making a 3.3% yield on
an annual basis. Aka, you took a $3 trillion 30
year long gamble with Apple just to end up making
less than a high interest savings account or a
government bond. As you can see, investing in
big tech at these valuations only makes sense
if you think that they’re gonna continue doubling
and tripling and quadrupling. If you think that
they’re just gonna stay the same, it’s a terrible
investment. For it to make sense to invest in a
stagnant Apple, their valuation would have to
come way down. Usually, the standard PE ratio
for mature companies with stagnant bottomlines
is 10. A lot of mature companies actually have PE
ratios less than 10. Ford is at 6.78, Verizon is
at 7.55, and United Airlines is at just 4.56, but
let’s give Apple the benefit of the doubt and call
it 10. This would mean that an investment in Apple
would pay back in 10 years. Aka, the annual yield
would be about 10% or a good amount higher than
savings accounts and bonds making the investment
worth the risk. But, for Apple to have a PE ratio
of 10, their valuation would have to fall to
$1 trillion which is obviously still a massive
amount but it’s also $2 trillion less than their
current valuation. And it’s the same case with
the rest of big tech. For Microsoft to come to PE
ratio of 10, they would have to shed $2 trillion.
Google would have to shed $1 trillion. Amazon
would have to shed $1.3 trillion. And Facebook
would have to shed $600 billion. And I think now
would be a good time to mention that Apple’s net
income has already been stagnating for 2 years,
Google’s has been declining for 2 years, Amazon
was briefly losing money, and Meta’s net income
was straight up cut in half. The only big tech
company that has managed to continue growing is
Microsoft and even that’s marginal. But, we don’t
even have to speculate as to what would happen
because this has already happened in the past.
GEN 1 TECH:
This transition from hyper growth to stagnation
happens in basically every industry whether it
be railroad companies, banking, oil, automotives,
you name it. Eventually, the exponentiality
of the industry wears off and valuations and
expectations settle down. This isn’t to say that
tech as a whole is done for. There’s plenty of
innovations that have yet to materialize whether
that be VR or AI or whatever else. But, it’s more
than likely that these new revolutions will be
led by a whole new generation of companies while
current big tech gets left behind just like gen 1
tech companies. Take Intel for example. These guys
are one of the most influential tech companies
of history. They were basically the father of
silicon wafers. Intel’s founder, Gordon Moore, was
literally the creator of Moore’s law. And as such,
they enjoyed tremendous growth between 1984
and 2000 of 90X. But, moving into the 2000s,
personal computer adoption peaked out. Everyone
who could possible get a computer already had
one and PC sales started to crater. In fact, PC
sales have been crashing for 10 years now. That
isn’t to say that the semi conductor instury as
a whole stopped growing though. Qualcomm, Nvidia,
and TSMC have all figured out new market segments
to continue exponential growth. The peak of the
PC market, however, marked the top for Intel who
has been struggling to recover for the past 23
years. And they’re just one example. Dell was
crashing so hard that Michael Dell had to come
out of retirement, take the company private,
and completely pivot to save the company. HP,
on the other hand, ended up splitting into 2
separate companies and that’s just within the
PC manufacturing industry. Cisco was once the
world’s largest company, but after their peak,
they would crash 80% and they have yet to recover
and it’s been 23 years. It’s the same case with
AT&T, and Verizon, and IBM, and Panasonic, and
Sony, and several other Gen 1 giants. The most
interesting thing about all of these companies
is that none of them particularly dropped the
ball. It’s not like Xerox or Yahoo where they
started losing market share and revenue started
plummeting. No, these companies still
dominate their respective industries,
and fundamentally speaking, they’re actually
doing better than ever. Cisco, for example,
is now making double the revenue that they
were back in 2000. And Intel is almost making
triple the profits. But, with their PE
ratios constantly falling towards 10,
all of this fundamental growth has meant nothing
in terms of stock returns. The only gen 1 company
that I can think of that actually overcame this
quicksand was Microsoft and it was by no means an
easy battle. It took Microsoft exactly 17 years
to climb out of this bottomless pit and that’s
not even accounting for inflation. If we account
for inflation, it actually took Microsoft 18 years
to finally live up to their dotcom valuations.
And during this time period, Microsoft’s revenue
had to grow 4 fold and their net income had to
grow 2.5 fold. In other words, if investors stop
believing in modern big tech’s growth story,
all of the companies that we know would have
to grow 2-3X in terms of revenue and net income
before the enjoy the same valuations. For Apple,
that means they’ll have to grow their net income
from $100 billion to $250 to $300 billion before
they enjoy the same $3 trillion valuation. Big
tech CEOs are well aware of this and that’s
why they’re scrambling to keep investor morale
high and more importantly racing to monetize.
THE RACE TO MONETIZE:
Likely the first big tech CEO
to come to this realization was Satya Nadella.
When he tookover Microsoft, he was taking over
from Steve Ballmer, one of the most controversial
tech CEOs of all time. Steve had grown Microsoft’s
revenue and profits by 3 fold, but Microsoft
stock had fallen 36% throughout his 14 years
of leadership. Satya saw this and decided that
he didn’t want to play this game of constantly
creating the next big thing and achieving infinite
growth. That was clearly a young company’s game
and Microsoft was very much a mature company. So,
what he did was transition Microsoft into becoming
a tech holding company. Basically, he settled
for modest growth with core Microsoft products
and started investing hundreds of billions in up
and coming companies with a bunch of exponential
growth left. Just recently, they closed their $69
billion deal to acquire Activision Blizzard. But,
the truth is, you can only do this so many times.
Eventually, you get so big that even a $100
billion acquisition doesn’t move the needle. The
second big tech CEO to realize this was Tim Cook.
In late 2018, he realized that iPhone sales were
not only starting to stagnate but decline. So,
he decided to take control of the narrative
and stop reporting unit sales for all Apple
products. Instead, he started focusing on services
like Apple Music and iCloud which was extremely
successful. But, now they’re at nearly a billion
paying users and running out of iPhone users to
monetize. The next big tech CEO to realize this
was Mark Zuckerberg. After the pandemic boom,
Mark realized that he had reached market
saturation with his social media empire. So,
he decided to start digging for new gold.
He committed $100 billion to the Metaverse,
changed the entire company’s name to Meta,
committed $33 billion to a new language model,
and tried to take on Twitter. But so far, none
of these new efforts have quite panned out. And
that brings us into Sundar Pichai, arguably the
last big tech CEO to realize this and as such,
his solution seems to be the most lack luster.
Google is basically just doubling down on the
cloud and packing in as many ads as they can.
But again, they can only pack in so many ads
and take this so far which brings us into the
core issue at hand. Big tech has enjoyed massive
growth and tremendous returns in their pursuit
to reach everyone on the entire planet. But now,
they’ve actually done it and they’re facing the
real challenge which is not even growing but
simply maintaining their sky high valuations
despite a stagnant user base. Every big tech
company has chosen a different path to overcome
this new quick sand of high interest rates and
market saturation. Will their efforts actually pan
out? Only time will tell but looking at history,
it ain’t gonna be easy. Someone else
who’s facing an existential crisis is
money burning startups who are struggling to get
more funding. Check out this video to learn more.